Bitte schön.
Hallo, guten Tag.
Mein Name ist Tekram Östfolder.
Ich bin auf dieser Station als Assistent Arzt tätig.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen
ein Aufnahmegespräch durchführen.
Alles in Ordnung für Sie?
Ja, gerne, Doktor.
Ok.
Zuerst benötige ich ein paar persönliche Daten
und dann können wir weiterführen.
Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Carmen Sikler.
Carmen Sikler?
Ja, genau.
Na, Sikler. Könnten Sie bitte
Ihre Pornamen und Nachnamen langsam
auf Deutsch beschreiben?
Ok.
Carmen, die Stabilität ist C, A, R, M, E, N.
Mit C?
Ja, C. C wie Cesar.
Und Sikler
Z
wie Zepelin,
G wie Ida,
E wie Emil,
G wie Gustav,
L wie Ludwig,
E wie Emil, R wie Richard.
Vielen Dank, Frau Sikler.
Frau Sikler, wie alt sind Sie?
Herr Doktor, ich bin 59 Jahre alt.
Frau Sikler, wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 1.2.1963.
1969, 1.
2.1963.
Ok, vielen Dank.
Frau Sikler, wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,57 Meter groß, Herr Doktor.
1,57?
Ja, genau.
Wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ich bin 76,6 Kilo schwer.
Ok, Frau Sikler. Was für eine Sitzung?
Ach, Herr Doktor, mir ist so übel.
Und ich habe starke Schmerzen.
Ich halte das kaum noch auf.
Ok, ich verstehe.
Zepelin, haben Sie die Schmerzen beschwerden?
Schon seit zwei Wochen.
Vielleicht. Aber seit gestern Abend
sind die Schmerzen
plötzlich richtig schlimm geworden, Herr Doktor.
Diese Schmerzen habe ich seit gestern.
Diese starken Schmerzen habe ich seit gestern Abend.
Ok.
Schmerzen haben Sie seit gestern und Übelkeit?
Ja, mir ist so übel seit gestern.
Ist das gleichzeitig mit dem Schmerz?
Nein, eigentlich, weil ich Schmerzen habe,
habe ich dreimal Cortimaxol gleichzeitig
einmal genommen.
Nach Einnahme dieses Medikaments
hatte ich oder habe ich diese Übelkeit.
Ich denke. Wegen Cortimaxol.
Ok.
Sie haben schon dreimal Cortimaxol
eingewiesen und wann?
Nein, einmal drei Stück Cortimaxol.
Einmal drei Stück. Wann? Gestern oder?
Gestern.
Ich dachte, es sei wieder eine
Hernwegsinfektion.
Hernwegsinnung.
Deswegen habe ich dieses Medikament wieder
eingewiesen.
Ich hatte früher
diese Beschwerden, ähnliche Beschwerden.
Sie haben schon früher ähnliche Beschwerden.
Ich würde gerne wissen, warum haben Sie
Cortimaxol so benutzen?
Einmal drei Stück.
Weil ich dachte, es sei wieder eine Hernwegsinfektion.
Wegen einer Erstichsereit oder?
Ich möchte möglichst schnell
Wirkung.
behalten, ja.
Handelt werden.
Ja, ok. Ok, ich verstehe.
Ok.
Sie haben schon gesagt, seit zwei Wochen
ähnliche Beschwerden haben Sie.
Und dann seit gestern, Sie haben sehr
starke Schmerzen und Übelkeit.
Und dann gestern haben Sie einmal
insgesamt drei Stück Cortimaxol
eingewiesen.
Frau Ziegler, wissen Sie, wie viel
von diesen Cortimaxol Tabletten?
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Ok.
Seit gestern sind diese Schmerzen
in der Woche wieder weg.
Herr Doktor, Sie hören gar nicht mehr
auf. Sie sind immer da.
Immer da.
Und wie gesagt, kann ich nicht das
aushalten. Bitte helfen Sie mir.
Ja, ok. Ok, ich verstehe.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen?
Könnten Sie mir mal beschreiben,
auf eine Schmerzskala, wobei ein 0
kein Schmerzen, ein 10 sehr starke
Schmerzen entspricht? Wie beschreiben Sie?
Mindestens 8. Vielleicht sogar 9, Herr Doktor.
Zuhause haben Sie dagegen ein Medikament ein oder?
Angenommen?
Wie gesagt, habe ich dagegen Medikament
eingenommen, aber...
Außer Cortimaxol.
Was für ein Medikament?
Schmerzmittel.
Schmerzmittel habe ich nie eingenommen.
Haben Sie gegen etwas Allergie, Frau Sigler?
Ich habe keine Allergie, Herr Doktor.
Keine Allergie. Und? Ok.
Ich rufe an die Krankenschwester an,
ich gebe ihm ein Schmerzmittel. Ok?
Frau Sigler, haben Sie noch Fieber?
Ja, seit ein paar Tagen.
Es ist ständig kalt und dann wieder heiß, Herr Doktor.
Haben Sie schon Fieber gemessen, oder?
Ja, ich habe schon gestern Abend gemessen.
Es war 38,8 Grad, Herr Doktor.
38,8 Grad.
Aber es kommt in Wellen, Herr Doktor.
Ja, ja, ja. Wellenartikel. Ok.
Was haben Sie gesagt? Ich konnte nicht verstehen.
Wellenartikel, oder?
Wellenartikel, ich weiß nicht.
Ich weiß nicht.
Das Fieber und die Schmerzen sind gleichzeitig, oder?
Fieber und Schmerzen? Nein. Ich denke nein.
Ok.
Wie gesagt, habe ich seit zwei Wochen endlich bestanden.
Ja, ja, ja.
Aber seit gestern sind die Schmerzen schlimmer geworden, Herr Doktor.
Ja, ja. Ok.
Und strahlen die Schmerzen irgendwo hinaus, Frau Ziegler?
Was meinen Sie mit Strahlung?
Zum Beispiel in den Rücken oder im Unterbauch.
Ah, ok. Ja, in den linken Unterbauch bis in den Leisten, Herr Doktor.
Das macht mir richtig Angst.
Unterbauch bis Leiste, linken seitlich Leiste.
In den Leisten, ja.
Ja, in den Leisten. Ok.
Frau Ziegler, gibt es etwas, das die Schmerzen verstärkt oder lindert?
Wenn ich mich bewege, verstärken sich die Schmerzen, ich denke.
In Ruhe fühle ich mich ein bisschen besser.
In Ruhe ein bisschen besser.
In Ruhe, ja.
Ok. Frau Ziegler, haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen?
Ja, Herr Doktor.
Seit gestern oder vor?
Ja, ständig. Besonders auch mal.
Ich komme, ja, ich muss zur Toilette immer, Herr Doktor.
Aber immer nur ganz wenig, Herr Doktor.
Ja, wenig, aber sehr oft.
Ja, ja, sehr oft.
Und das ist sehr schwer für mich. Es brennt furchtbar, Herr Doktor, beim Wasserlassen.
Ich spüre eine brennende Gefühl.
Ja, Sie haben noch eine brennende Gefühl beim Wasserlassen.
Ja, ich verstehe. Und welche Farbe hat der Urin?
Herr Doktor, seit gestern ist er rötlich. Das macht mir auch richtig Angst.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Und richtig stark oder ungewöhnlich haben Sie etwas bemerkt?
Ja, es stinkt, Herr Doktor, es stinkt.
Und es sieht komisch aus.
Wie art der Urin?
Total trüb.
Total trüb?
Ja.
Seit wann der Urin trüb war?
Seit Wochen?
Ich habe es gestern bemerkt.
Aber ich weiß nicht, seit wann.
Das habe ich.
Wie viel Urin haben Sie täglich? Oder wie viel Wasser trinken Sie?
Ich trinke ausreichendes Wasser. Vielleicht mehr als sonst trinke ich Wasser. Aber wie gesagt...
Zum Beispiel ca. zwei Liter haben Sie täglich Wasser trinken oder?
Ich schaute darauf. Aber ich schwitze auch, Herr Doktor.
Seit gestern schwitze ich auch sehr viel.
Und ist der Handstand schwach oder stark? Sie haben schon gesagt, eine kleine Menge.
Sie kann es sein, Herr Doktor. Es ist eine sehr kleine Menge.
Haben Sie Schnellfrost in der Nacht?
Schnellfrost nicht, aber ich schwitze, Herr Doktor.
Wie ist Ihr Apathit?
Gar keine, Herr Doktor. Mir ist schon beim Gedanken an das Essen übel.
Wie gesagt habe ich Übelkeit, Herr Doktor.
Übelkeit, Übelkeit.
Wenn man Übelkeit hat, kann man nicht essen.
Ja natürlich. Und haben Sie noch Erblichung?
Ja, Herr Doktor. Ich musste mich auch einmal übergeben. Es war schrecklich.
Wie sah es aus?
Nur Essensreste, Herr Doktor. Es gab nur Essensreste.
Nach dem Antibiotikum oder?
Ja, wegen Übelkeit. Es gibt eine Zusammenhänge zwischen Ihnen.
Nach Einnahme von Antibiotikum hatte ich Übelkeit. Weil ich Übelkeit habe, musste ich mich übergeben.
Ok, ich verstehe. Haben Sie die letzte Zeit Gewicht ab oder zugenommen?
Nein, mein Gewicht ist stabil, Herr Doktor.
Stabil? Hatten Sie in der Vergangenheit schon ein halbes Infekt?
Ja, wie gesagt hatte ich nicht nur einmal, sondern auch mehrmals solche Beschwerden.
Zum Beispiel, weil ich 15 Jahre alt war, hatte ich eine Nierenentzündung.
Aber ich weiß nicht genau die Name dieser Krankheit.
Dann hatte ich mehrmals solche Beschwerden mit meinen Nieren.
Ok, haben Sie Probleme beim Stuhlgang?
Ja, ich habe auch Durchfall, Herr Doktor. Seit gestern.
Ja, 3 bis 4 Mal. Ganz wässrig. Es war ganz wässrig, Herr Doktor.
Nach der Einnahme von Antibiotikum?
Ja, wie gesagt, ja.
Ok, ok. Und haben Sie Sorgenbrünen oder Sauerstoff?
Nein, das habe ich nicht.
Aber natürlich nach dem Erbrechen fühle ich mich solche Schmecken in meinem Mund.
Sauerstoff, meine ich.
Schlafen Sie gut?
Nein, Herr Doktor. Ganz schlecht. Wegen der Schmerzen und dem stelligen Wasserlassen.
Ich bin fix und fertig, Herr Doktor.
Ok, verstehe. Wegen Schmerzen haben Sie auch eine Schlafstörung.
Und Frau Ziegler, sind Sie schon im Wechseljahr?
Ja, Herr Doktor. Ich bin seit einigen Jahren im Wechseljahr.
Wann war die letzte Zeit?
Ich erinnere mich nicht, aber vielleicht vor 9 Jahren. Damals war es unregelmäßig.
Vielleicht 9 Jahre.
Ca. 10 Jahre oder?
Ja, 10 Jahre.
Ok, besuchen Sie regelmäßig Ihren Frauenarzt?
Ja, Herr Doktor.
Besuchweiserärzt.
Aber ich habe Probleme beim Geschlechtsverkehr. Das tut auch weh, Herr Doktor.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Beim Geschlechtsverkehr tut das auch weh, Herr Doktor. Vielleicht möchten Sie wissen.
Ok.
Frau Ziegler, haben Sie noch irgendwelche chronischen Erkrankungen?
Sie haben schon gesagt, mit 15 Jahren lebt sie. Sie haben noch eine Niereentzündung. Und dann?
Ja, deswegen muss ich regelmäßig Kontrolle bei Urologen suchen.
Und ich leide seit 5 Jahren an Bluthochdruck, Herr Doktor.
Seit 5 Jahren Bluthochdruck. Gibt es noch?
Nein. Seit 5 Jahren.
Ok.
Würden Sie schon mal operieren, Frau Ziegler?
Herr Doktor, ja. Mit 10 Jahren wurde bei mir eine Blindenbarm entfernt.
Und mit 18 Jahren wurde mein Blindenbarm entfernt.
Mit 15 Jahren?
Mit 10 Jahren wurde bei mir eine Mandelentfernung geführt.
Und mit 18 Jahren?
Mit 18 Jahren. Ja. Und ich hatte auch einen Kaiserschnitt vor 25 Jahren. Ist das auch eine Operation?
Ja, natürlich.
Sollten Sie wissen?
Kaiserschnitt.
Ja.
Ein Geburtsgeburt. Haben Sie eine Kinderfrage, Frau Ziegler?
Ja, ich habe eine Tochter.
Eine Kaiserschnitt.
Sie hat keine Kaiserschnitt, Herr Doktor.
Sie hat schon gerade Kaiserschnitt gesagt.
Ich hatte Kaiserschnitt.
Vor 25 Jahren eine Kaiserschnitt. Ich denke, sechs Jahre. Ok.
Frau Ziegler, haben Sie Allergien?
Sie hat gesagt, ich habe keine Allergien.
Eine Allergie, ja. Sie haben es schon gesagt.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig Medikamente gegen Bluthochdruck?
Ja, Herr Doktor.
Was nehmen Sie?
Ich nehme auch gut kontrolliert mit Hilfe dieser Medikamente. Ich nehme dagegen Nebivolol und Candesartan ein.
Nebivolol 10 mg und Candesartan 4 mg.
4 mg Candesartan.
Und zur Magenschutzung nehme ich Omeprazole ein.
Wie viel Milch haben Sie?
Ich weiß nicht, Herr Doktor.
Ok.
Vielleicht 20, aber ich habe keine Ahnung.
Frau Ziegler, sind Sie voll geimpft?
Ja, Herr Doktor. Vollständig geimpft.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit im Ausland gereist?
Nein, Herr Doktor.
Ich reiße.
Trinken Sie? Frau Ziegler, rauchen Sie?
Nein, Herr Doktor. Ich rauche nicht.
Ok, super.
Gut zu hören.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Gelegentlich trinke ich 6 oder Wein.
Nicht so viel. Ein Glas oder zwei Glas.
Ein Glas am Wochenende oder pro Woche?
Oder eher selten.
Sehr selten. Ok.
Bitte nehmen Sie diese Frage nicht persönlich.
Haben Sie schon einmal Drogen konsumiert?
Einmal oder mehr mal. Habe ich nie das konsumiert.
Aber warum fragen Sie das?
Das ist eine Routinefrage.
Aber machen Sie keine Sorge.
Aufgrund der Schwagerfläche darf ich Ihre Angaben mit niemandem teilen.
Das Problem ist nicht, dass Sie miteinander teilen.
Das Problem ist, warum ist es eine medizinische Frage?
Weil Drogen Nebenwirkungen haben können.
Deswegen müssen wir immer diese Frage stellen.
Danke.
Vielen Dank.
Frau Ziegler, sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, ich bin verheiratet.
Ich wohne mit meinem Mann zusammen.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Wie gesagt habe ich eine Tochter.
Eine Tochter?
Ja.
Ist sie gesund?
Ja, Gott sei Dank ist sie gesund und hat keine Kaiserscheine.
Gut.
Und Frau Ziegler, leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Mein Vater lebt ja noch.
Aber leider ist meine Mutter als sie jung war, nach einer Herzopie verstorben.
Es tut mir leid, es tut mir sehr leid für die Erdenverlust.
Sie hatte auch Nierenprobleme, Herr Doktor.
Nierenprobleme?
Sie war dialysenpflichtig und hatte eine Nieren-Transplantation.
Sie hatte auch eine Nieren-Transplantation.
Sehr wichtige Information für uns.
Gott sei Dank für die Information.
Mein Vater hat Bluthochdruck, Herr Doktor.
Ihr Vater hat noch einen unter Kontrolle oder?
Ich hoffe es, aber ich weiß nicht.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Nein Herr Doktor, ich bin Einzelkind.
Frau Ziegler, letzte Frage.
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Herr Doktor, ich bin eingestellt beim Einwohnermeldamt.
Einwohnermeldamt?
Ja.
Beim Rathaus?
Okay.
Frau Ziegler, ich bin nun mit meinen Fragen fertig.
Haben Sie noch Fragen?
Nein Herr Doktor, aber ich würde gerne wissen, was ich habe.
Frau Ziegler, ich habe einen Verdacht auf Nierenentzündung.
Aber das bleibt nur eine Vermutung.
Deshalb müssen wir weiter untersuchen, durchführen, um meinen Verdacht zu bestätigen.
Ich werde zuerst körperliche Untersuchungen machen, dann ein paar Blut abnehmen und weitere Untersuchungen durchführen.
Sobald die Ergebnisse vorliegen, bespreche ich mit meinem Obers.
Dann komme ich zu Ihnen und erzähle Ihnen alles.
Danke.
Sie müssen jetzt warten und dann komme ich zu Ihnen.
Okay Herr Doktor, ich warte auf Sie.
Vielen Dank Frau Ziegler.
Frau Ziegler, darf ich ein paar Fragen stellen?
Ja natürlich, bitte.
Für die Patienten?
Ja.
Wie ist der Schmerzkorrektor? Könnten Sie bitte erzählen?
Frau Doktor, so klopfend und tochend, als würde jemand mit einem Hammer dagegen schlagen.
Klopfend und tochend.
Wo genau sind diese Schmerzen?
In den Rücken, vielleicht unter Rücken.
Ich kann sagen auch im Lendenbereich.
Linkseitige?
Ja ja, linkseitige.
Ist Ihnen der Bluthochdruck gut eingestellt?
Ja ja, ich messe regelmäßig und besuche meinen Hausarzt regelmäßig.
Die letzte Messung war 120 zu 70.
Okay, auch besuchen Sie vielleicht Urologen regelmäßig?
Ja, wie gesagt, muss ich die Urologen wegen meiner vorherigen Nierenprobleme besuchen.
Okay. Und noch habe ich etwas.
Haben Sie Gewichtveränderung in der letzten Zeit?
Nein, wie gesagt, ist mein Gewicht im Axtellnummer.
Ich vermute, Ihr Schlafen ist nicht gut.
Ja, diese Frage wurde gestellt.
Okay, danke schön.
Perkabla?
Möchtest du einen Labuanrück machen?
Ja.
Klink, klink.
Ja, hallo, wie soll ich hier?
Frau Müller am Apparat.
Guten Tag Frau Müller.
Herr Jansen, Kaliumwert liegt 2,6 mmol pro Liter.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihre Oberarztin weiterleiten?
Ja, natürlich Frau Müller.
Jansen mit Jod.
Ja, okay.
Danke, tschüss.
Bitte schön.
Guten Tag Frau Oberarztin.
Was haben Sie heute für uns?
Ja, ich habe einen neuen Patienten.
Aber bevor ich meinen Patienten vorstelle,
möchte ich mit Ihnen einen wichtigsten Beitrag mitteilen.
Frau Jansen, ein Kaliumwert von 2,6 mmol pro Liter,
dieser Wert ist deutlich erniedrigt, entspricht an Hypokalämie.
Was ist die Ursache für Hypokalämie?
Für Hypokalämie ist die Ursache meistens Diuretika,
erbringend Diäro und Asidose, respiratorische oder metabolische Asidose.
Welche Symptome erwarten Sie bei Hypokalämie?
Am wichtigsten Symptom bei Hypokalämie ist Kamaflama,
aber es gibt auch Muskelkräfte, Schwäche, Krampf,
Reflexabschwächung, Störungen, Obstpassungen, Blasenlähmung
und generell Herzrhythmusstörungen.
Okay, wie können Sie die behandeln?
Die erste Form ist über 2,5.
Kaliumwerte erniedrigt, Bananen, Obst, Gemüse und
die schwere Form ist unter 2,5.
Paranthra, Kaliumchlorid und EKG und Vitalparameterkontrolle.
Okay, was haben Sie noch?
Ich habe heute einen neuen Patienten.
Es geht um Frau Carmen Ziegler, 59 Jahre alt, geboren am 1.2.1963,
1,57 Meter groß und 76,6 Kilo wiegt.
Frau Carmen, die sich heute bei uns gestellt hat,
wegen gestern Abend bestehende klopfende linkseitige
Oberbauchschmerzen vor.
Laut Angaben der Patienten, die Schmerzen plötzlich aufgetreten
und sie berichtet, dass die Schmerzen ca. 2 oder 3 Wochen langsam aufgetreten,
aber am Anfang war die Schmerzintensität sehr leicht und
in der Mitte war es Schilma.
Entschuldigung, Sie haben schon erwähnt, dass die Schmerzen
gestern Abend plötzlich aufgetreten sind.
Gibt es eine bestimmte Auslösung für die Schmerzen?
Ich habe die gefragt.
Okay.
Und Sie haben schon erwähnt?
Ja, die Patienten hatten ca. 2 Wochen Schmerzen,
aber die Schmerzen waren sehr leicht.
Seit gestern, ich korrigiere, haben die Schmerzen nicht plötzlich aufgetreten,
seit 2 Wochen waren es leicht.
Seit gestern Abend die Schmerzen sind im Oberbauch.
Linkseitige Oberbauchschmerzen.
Ja, linkseitige Oberbauchschmerzen und in den Flanken.
Okay, bitte schön, weiter.
Seit gestern Abend hat die Patient 38,8 Grad Celsius Fibra
und die Schmerzen strahlen den linken Unterbauch bis zur linkseitigen Leiste aus.
Die Schmerzen verstärkt beim Bewegung, die Schmerzen lindert in Ruhe.
Gleichzeitig hatten die Patienten ständig Schmerzen beim Wasserlassen.
Was ist Fachbegriff?
Die Zürich.
Sie hatten beim Wasserlassen die Zürich, die Übrigenmenge sei wenig.
Sie sollen hier alle Fachbegriffe benutzen.
Begleitet klagt sie über die Zürich, Polak Zürich, Polyküri.
Sie klagt über, dass die Polak Zürich, Polak Zürich, nicht Polak Zürich, Polak Zürich.
Sie müssen oft auf die Toilette gehen, aber jedes Mal hat sie weniger Üren.
Das bedeutet, Polyküri bedeutet, sie haben oft und viel Menge.
Polyüri bedeutet, sie haben viel Menge Üren.
Polyküri bedeutet, sie haben viel weniger Üren.
Polyküri bedeutet, sie haben oft und viel weniger Üren.
Ich habe gehört, Polyüri, Polyküri, vielleicht gleich.
Polyküri, ja ich wieder kontrolliere meine Note, aber Polyküri habe ich erst mal gehört.
Ich weiß nicht, die deutsche Literatur.
Okay, danke für die Information.
Polyküri.
Vielleicht habe ich falsch gesagt. Ich kontrolliere sie, ich kann es nicht machen.
Sie berichtet, dass die Schmerzen im linken Unterbauch und aus Strahlen im linken Leiste, Schmerzintensität liegt bei 8 von 10.
Sie erwähnt, dass sie vor zwei Wochen ähnliche Beschwerden hatten.
Seit gestern hat sie einmal drei Tabletten Kotrimaxazol mit unklaren Dosis angenommen.
Begleitend klagt sie über Fieber.
Woher hat sie Kotrimaxazol gefunden?
Wer hat das in und verschrieben?
Ohne, ohne Erst-Scherat. Die Patientin hat gesagt, ja ich nehme selbst unerst-scherat.
Die Medikament war schon aus.
Okay.
Die Patientin hat diese Medikament mit drei Stück selbst angenommen.
Sie klagt über gestern einmal Durchfall.
Wegen dieser Schmerzen eine Schlafstörung.
Ansonsten die Begezichtspanale ist unauffällig.
Entschuldigung, einmal Durchfall oder?
Ja, einmal Durchfall.
Okay, ich habe drei oder viermal gehört.
Okay.
Ich habe das nur einmal notiert.
Und bei der Vorerkrankung erwähnte sie, mit 15. Lebensjahre, er hatte eine Nierenentzündung.
Sie war sehr alt und kontrollierte regelmäßig ihre Urologen.
Seit fünf Jahren leidet sie eine arterielle Hypertonie.
Dagegen nimmt sie Nebulol 10 mg und Candesartan 4 mg regelmäßig ein.
Bei der Voroperation erwähnte sie, mit 18. Lebensjahre, dass bei ihr ein Tonsilektrum durchgeführt wurde.
Mit 18. Lebensjahre wurde bei ihr ein Appendektum durchgeführt.
Und vor 25 Jahren hatte sie einen Kaiserschnitt.
Sie hatte keine Allergien. Sie ist nicht Rauchern.
Regellich Alkohol konsumieren. Ein Glas Wein am Wochenende wurde beacht.
Drogenkonsum wurde verneint.
Die Familienanamnese ergab, dass der Vater an arterieller Hypertonie leidet.
Die Mutter ist an einer Herzoperation verstorben.
Die Mutter hatte Nierenprobleme. Sie war dialysflüchtig.
Bei ihr wurde Nierentransplantation durchgeführt.
Sie hat keine Geschwister. Sie ist bei einem Wohnungsmeldungsamt verheiratet.
Sie ist eine Tochter. Sie ist gesund.
Auch die Anamnese hat einen Verdacht auf Nierenentzündung.
Was ist Nierenentzündung? Was bedeutet Nierenentzündung?
Nierenentzündung ist die Diagnose von Pyelonephritis.
Wofür ist es?
Flankschmerzen, Fieber, Vorgehensweise, Durchfall, Apathetlosigkeit, Schlafstörungen, Schwitzen.
Welche Risikofaktoren hat diese Patienten?
Die Risikofaktoren sind weibliche Gesichter und positive.
Sie hat Nierenentzündung. Die Mutter hatte auch ähnliche Vorgesichten.
Sie war dialysflüchtig. Bei ihr wurde Nierentransplantation durchgeführt.
Gibt es noch eine kongentale Anomalie?
Welche Differenzialdiagnose?
Die Anomalie ist eine kongentale Anomalie.
Welche Diagnose würden Sie durchführen?
Ich würde gerne zuerst alle körperlichen Untersuchungen durchführen.
Und dann Blut für das Labor.
Worauf achten Sie bei Körperleumententzündung?
Fieber, Abwärtsspannung, Druck, Empfindlichkeit.
Besonders bei Piole-Nefritis.
Welche Unterzuchtung?
Ich habe es gerade kaputt gemacht.
Ich kann nicht sagen.
Was ist das?
Klopfen schmerzen.
Wie bitte?
Normalerweise bei Piole-Nefritis
untersuchen wir Klopfen schmerzen.
Klopfen schmerzen, aber noch andere Begriffe.
Klopfen schmerzen.
Klopfen-Untersuchung.
Hauptsache ist Klopfen.
Klopfen, aber bei der Technologie gibt es noch andere Terminologien.
Mir gefällt es nicht ein,
es gibt noch andere professionelle Begriffe.
Aber ich habe es mir nicht aufgefallen.
Klopfen, Empfindlichkeit.
Klopfen, Fieber.
Fieber ist sehr wichtig.
Manche Seiten sind Abwehrspannung oder Druckempfindlichkeit.
Superpupasche Empfindlichkeit.
Ich werde Blut für das Labor abnehmen.
Im Labor ein großes Blutbild.
Leber- und Nierenwerte und CAP und Übungsstatus und Stuhlstatus.
Das kontrolliere ich.
Ich werde die Nierenultrachelle durchführen.
Was ist das für eine Nierenultrachelle?
Das ist ein Piole-Nefritis.
Warum ist das eine Nierenultrachelle?
Für die akute Piole-Nefritis gibt es keine bestimmte radiologische Befunde.
Wenn es eine pathologische kongentale Anomalie oder Stein oder andere Pathologie gibt,
könnte das behilflich sein.
Aber nur bei der Piole-Nefritis ist eine Nierenultrachelle nicht geholfen.
Sie haben schon einen Piole-Nefritis und eine kongentale Harnweg-Anomalie.
Um Ihren Piole-Nefritis auszuschließen, möchten Sie eine Nierenultrachelle durchführen.
Natürlich.
Die Nierenultrachelle ist ein Routine.
Es gibt keine Pathologie.
Sie muss eine körperliche Untersuchung und einen urologischen oder nephrologischen Konsil anfordern.
Wie können Sie die Patienten behandeln?
Die Nierenultrachelle ist eine kulturelle Kulturen.
Die kulturelle Kulturen ist positiv.
Sie ist ein Antibiotik.
Wird die Nierenultrachelle nicht geholfen werden?
Natürlich. Sie haben schon gesagt, dass es eine Anpirische gibt.
Kalkuliertetherapie.
Als erste Maßnahme Pursical Sufone Elektrolysisition.
Kalkulierte Antibiotik.
Dann Beton.
Nach der Ausrüstung der Kalkulierte Antibiotik verändert.
Die Antibiotik verändert.
Aber nicht immer.
Möchten Sie die Patienten stationär aufnehmen oder ambulant behandeln?
Natürlich werden die Patienten stationär aufnehmen.
Warum?
Der nächste Schritt ist immer die Urosopsis.
Deswegen müssen die Patienten stationär aufnehmen.
Wie können Sie die Urosopsis und die Kalkulierte Antibiotik beenden?
Die Kalkulierte Antibiotik.
Wie können Sie die Kalkulierte Antibiotik beenden?
Was ist mit der Kalkulierte Antibiotik?
Möchten Sie die Kalkulierte Antibiotik beenden?
Sie haben schon gesagt, dass es eine Kalkulierte Antibiotik mit der Kalkulierte Antibiotik gibt.
Gibt es noch andere Kalkulierte Antibiotik?
Zum Beispiel die Papillonekrose, die Hydronefrose.
Jede Kalkulierte Antibiotik geht ab und zu langsam und schnell.
Die Tübel sind nekrose.
Deswegen geht es um eine chronische, renale Nireinsuffizienz.
Deswegen soll man nach der Infektion immer mit einer Syntographie die Nieren kontrollieren lassen.
Ob eine Nekrose vorhanden ist?
Ja, Nekroseinfarkte und wie ist die Funktion bei Nieren.
Vielen Dank.
Wenn Sie das Kalkulierte Antibiotik mit der Kalkulierte Antibiotik beenden, müssen Sie es nicht verbreiten.
Sie haben es dort geschrieben.
Nein, ich habe noch etwas anderes.
Ich habe etwas verpasst, das ich nicht in der Klinik erinnere.
Dann schau dir das an.
Die Anamnesie war nicht schlecht, aber die Frage von Woe ist sehr wichtig.
Die Frage von Charakter ist auch wichtig, um die Nieren zu bezeichnen.
Hier ist die Kulapfund, hier ist die Krampffartige.
Wenn ich das Kalkulierte Antibiotik bezeichne, dann wird die Frage von Woe bezeichnet.
Woe ist ein Ort, in dem die Doktorin die Anamnesie bezeichnen muss.
Wenn der Patient in Unterdenbriken sagt, dann in der Mitte, linksightige, rechtsightige.
Wenn er in der Mitte sagt, dann in der Lumbarge.
Wenn er in linksightige sagt, dann in der Nieren.
Die Anamnesie von Woe war gut, aber die Anamnesie von Charakter und Woe war nicht gut.
Auch die Anamnesie von Woe war gut, aber die Anamnesie von Charakter und Woe war nicht gut.
Du hast die Anamnesen von Arthritis, die Anamnesen von Arthritis, die du im Arthritis-Kreis hast, gefragt.
Hier hast du sie gefragt. Ich glaube, das war gut.
Hier reden wir jetzt auch um die Zeit, um die Zeit zu kürzen.
Die Fragen, die du brauchst, nicht fragen.
Für example, dass der Vater nicht in der Hypertension ist, ist nicht wichtig.
Da muss man nicht wagen.
Wenn du das sagst, muss man nicht wagen.
Da muss man nicht Zeit verlieren.
Für example, dieser Patient, der Arthritis in Geşirechtvekeh hat gesagt.
Normalerweise gibt es so etwas.
Aber das kann uns wichtig sein.
Wenn du in so ein Gebiet bist, kannst du dir Zeit wagen.
Das kann dir wichtig sein.
Das kann dir nicht anders werden.
Aber wenn so etwas passiert, was kann man fragen?
Das kann man aus Auslösen als Faktor denken.
Das war schon da, da war Infektion.
Dann hat er in der Zeit einen Geist gemacht.
Kann ich das erzählen?
Ja, ja.
Ich bin hier auf unnötige Dinge gekommen.
Ich habe keine Fragen gestellt.
Ich hoffe, dass es in der Prüfung kommen wird.
Nein, nein.
Der Vater hatte nur die Frage, ob die Hypertension nicht zu verhindern ist.
Der Patient hat es gesagt.
Du hast eine sehr schöne Gynäkologische Anamnese gemacht.
In der Gynäkologischen Anamnese hat er gesagt, dass du eine Schmerzenbarm-Gecheh-Lechtvekeh.
Er hat gesagt, dass du eine Arme im Bein hast.
Vielleicht kannst du das sagen.
Du hast schon 7,5.
Ich habe mir gedacht, dass es mir gut wäre,
dass ich die Anamnese mit meinem Schmerz habe.
Ich habe keine weiteren Fragen.
Ich habe keine große Läden oder einen Unterschied.
Ihr Schmerz war sehr gut.
Ihr wart auch gut in den Reaktionen.
Sie haben nur am Anfang eine Antibiotik und ohne Ars-Liherat.
Du hast versucht, das zu erklären, wie du es bekommst.
Nur eine Antibiotik und ohne Ars-Liherat.
Das ist ein Schmerz, das du nicht bekommst.
Das war gut.
Ihr könnt euch selbst verabschieden.
Aber wenn ihr euch verabschiedet ...
Ich habe mich sehr schlecht verabschiedet.
Ich habe nichts mehr gemacht.
Das ist mein Thema.
Deswegen ist es etwas, das man nicht erwarten kann.
Aber weil es dein Thema ist,
kannst du dich sicherer und sicherer beantworten.
Das ist sehr gut.
Im Übrigen ist die Polaküri und die Polakizuri die gleiche Sache.
Ich habe nie von Polaküri gesprochen.
Die Beispiele haben Polakizuri.
Die beiden sind die gleiche Sache.
Es gibt nur ein wenig Arthrose, aber es ist oft Arthrose.
Poliüri ist immer so, wie es in der Gegend so ist.
Poliüri ist ...
Polikizuri ist ein sehr schweres Thema.
Das ist oft so.
Ich habe in der ersten Sitzung Poliüri gehört.
Jetzt hast du Poliüri gesagt.
Ich habe in der Vakation Polaküri gesagt.
Ich habe von dir Poliüri gehört.
Deswegen habe ich das dort bestätigt.
Poliüri ist ein Thema.
Polikizuri ist ein Thema.
Ja, oft.
Und die Polykyse ist auch die gleiche Sache.
Okay, ich habe die Polykyse auch gehört.
So, vielen Dank für die Arbeit.
Bitte, Ipek.
Ich glaube, dass ich heute auch Sie bin.
Ich hoffe, dass ich es nicht mache.
Ich werde die Kamera öffnen.
Ja.
Guten Tag.
Ich habe heute eine Patientin aufgenommen.
Sie ist Carmen Cikla, 63 Jahre alt, geboren am 01.02.1963.
Sie ist 1,57 Meter groß und wiegt 76,6 Kg.
Seit gestern Abend kann sie uns wegen der Verschleunigung
und der linkseitigen Flankenschmerzen berichten.
Sie berichtet diese Schmerzen wie klopfend, pochend,
progredient und persistierend.
Sie hatte diese Beschwerden aber leichter.
Sie hatte diese Beschwerden aber leichter seit zwei Wochen.
Diese Schmerzen sind in der Ruhe verlindert,
bei Belastung verstärkt.
Sie erwähnt, dass gestern Abend drei Tabletten
in der Ruhe verlindert werden.
Nach der Einnahme der drei Tabletten
berichtet sie,
erbrechen und die Erhöhung
begleitet, erbrechen,
Essenreste und Durchfall
seit gestern zwei bis drei Mal wässrig.
Auch nach dem Antibiotikum Einnahme.
Seit ein paar Tagen berichtet sie
velenartige Fieber.
Gestern Abend war die Temperatur 38,8 Grad Celsius.
Sie hat keine Bixion beschwert.
Sie hat begleitende Symptome.
Sie berichtet Püri, Polyaksyrie und
Rotürin.
Und Trüblikürin.
Rotürin, Hematüri.
Trot trinkt genug Wasser.
An Vorerkrankungen leidet sie seit 15 Jahren
Nierenentzündung.
Ich werde eine Verbindung mit ihren
Urologen setzen.
Wie heißt das oder so, würde ich gerne fragen.
Und Bluthochdruck.
Sie hat seit fünf Jahren
Arterielle Hypertonie.
Sie berichtet auch Arterielle Hypertonie.
Dagegen nimmt sie 10 Milligramm Nebivolol
und kann das artan 4 Milligramm ein.
Bei Bedarf nimmt sie auch
Omeprolol und Claradosis.
Sie hat keine Relevanz für Operationen und Allergien.
Sie trinkt Alkohol, ein oder zwei Gläser Wein,
oder weniger als wöchentlich.
Nikotin und Drogenkonsum würden verneint.
An Familienanamnese leidet ihr Vater
Arterielle Hypertonie und ihr Mutter
leidet ihre Mutter
mit Nierenentzündung und hat eine
Nieren-Transplantation.
Aber sie ist während Herz-OP gestorben.
Sie ist vollständig geimpft.
Sie ist angestellt an einem Wohnmeldepartner.
Sie hat eine Tochter.
Nach dem Anamnesenangaben habe ich einen Verdacht auf
Pyronephritis.
Als Differentialdiagnose kommen Akute Schub
Glymerelo-Nephritis oder Urolithiasis in Betracht.
Zu weiterer Erklärung würde ich gerne
körperliche Untersuchungen,
besonders linkseitige und
klopfende, abtasten.
Er berichtet auch, dass diese Schmerzen
in den linken Unterbauch,
in den linken Leisten ausgetragen werden.
Deswegen würde ich gerne abtasten.
Ich würde gerne die Schmerzen in den
linken Unterbauch,
die Schmerzen in den linken Unterbauch,
Sie können überprüfen.
Und nach dem Ja würde ich gerne sofort
Entschuldigung, ich habe dieses Gespräch untergebracht.
Damals habe ich Zugang einlagen
und eine Novalgene und Spasspolitik gegeben.
Nach dem Ergebnis würde ich auch
Antibiotikum verabreichen.
Ich würde gerne diese Patienten stationär aufnehmen.
Besonders hat sie Nierenentzündung,
Bluthochdruck, starke Schmerzen.
Vielleicht gibt es bei der Ultraschallhydronephrose
besonders beobachte ich unter den Augen.
Ich kann dir das vorlesen,
wie ich das vorlesen kann.
Ich kann dir dass vorlesen,
Ich frage hier die Probleme.
Ich frage in der Hapbechwerde.
Ich habe die andere Schrift gefragt.
Dann beginne ich zu fragen was alas.
Wenn mir eine Frage kommt,
dann frage ich hier alles was was alas.
Wie oft müssen sie auf die Toilette gehen?
Haben sie Schmerzen oder Brennendes Gefühle bei was alas?
Wie viel üben haben sie?
Wie sonst?
Oder mehr als sonst?
Wenige als sonst?
Wie oft müssen sie auf die Toilette gehen?
Wer hat die Hapbechwerde?
Gibt es Blut im Übrigen?
Ich frage hier alles was ich hier fragen kann.
Dann frage ich hier die Probleme.
Wenn es Probleme gibt,
dann frage ich hier die Hapbechwerde.
Wie oft müssen sie auf die Toilette gehen?
Gibt es Blut im Übrigen?
Wenn ich da eine Schmerzprobleme habe,
dann frage ich hier auch die Probleme.
Dann frage ich hier Fiberspuren.
Wie oft werden sie auf die Toilette gehen?
Gewicht, Fparty?
Ist hier mal eine Schmerzprobleme.
Und sch
Inestezide, Ungewalt, Ausfluss, Vaginala Ausfluss, Schmelz im Baumeck, Gechlecht, Fäkea.
Glymere und Nephritis sind die grundlegenden Faktoren der Systeme.
Dass es ein Ergänzungsverhältnis gibt, dass es ein Tensionverhältnis gibt,
oder dass es ein körperliches Ergänzungsverhältnis gibt.
Sie können sich nicht alle beantworten, aber ich habe ein paar Fragen darüber.
Habt ihr einen Ergänzungsverhältnis? Habt ihr den Ergänzungsverhältnis in eurem Körper gemerkt?
Ist der Übring ein bisschen schäumig?
Ich habe diese Frage schon immer gefragt.
Wenn Glymere und Nephritis gesagt werden,
dann ist es so.
Es gibt verschiedene Fragen.
Und jetzt,
hier ist es ein bisschen anders.
Aber in meinem Begriff mit Pyrrole und Nephritis ist es so.
Der Patient hat gestern eine starke Tasse aufgetreten,
und dann ist er auf dem Kloffund,
und dann wird die Schmerzenkarte entstanden.
Und der Patient,
zwei Wochen vorher,
hat es gesagt, dass er 50-50-5-Verdigungen hat.
Das bedeutet, dass es ein bisschen ein Mixion-Verdigungen gibt.
Das ist sehr komplex.
Es gibt keine genannten Erfahrung,
wie es genau ist.
Aber ich habe es selbst verstanden,
dass es zwei Wochen vorher diese Begegnungen gab.
Das ist schon oft eine Hydroseinfektion.
Es gab diese Begegnungen zwei Wochen vorher.
Die Antibiotik wurde geschlossen,
die Antibiotik wurde etwas verwendet,
die Symptome, die sie sich überwunden haben,
aber die Tatsache war nicht voll.
Und dann, als es gestern Abend war,
hat die Antibiotik, die vorher geschlossen wurde,
die drei Antibiotiken, die sie vorher verwendet haben,
aber die drei Antibiotiken, die sie jetzt verwendet haben,
sind die Antibiotiken, die sie jetzt verwendet haben.
Da ist es wichtig,
dass der Patient Purellenephritis ist
und die Handwerk-Infektion nicht getätigt wurde.
Das war die Handwerk-Infektion.
Jetzt ist es Purellenephritis.
Diese zwei Gründe sind die,
dass es die Bakterien, die vom Boden her ausgehen,
oder die, die vom Wagen her ausgehen,
Ich habe es so gemacht, dass ich es so gemacht habe.
So ist es.
In Reaktionen ist es wichtig, die Antibiotik in die Abwechslung zu nehmen.
Ein Antibiotiker sagt, wer dir das geschrieben hat, warum er das geschrieben hat,
wann du es benutzt hast, und du hast die Antibiotik nicht ausgebildet.
Du bist zu Hause.
Wenn du diese Schreie bekommst, ist es wichtig, die Abwechslung zu nehmen.
Das ist eine wichtige Reaktion.
Und es ist wichtig, die Situation zu verstehen.
Dann ist es wichtig, diese Reaktion zu machen.
Eine Medikament, die du benutzt hast,
weil das Medikament nicht ausgebildet werden kann.
Wenn du die Antibiotik in die Abwechslung hast,
dann ist es wichtig, die Abwechslung zu nehmen.
Du musst die Antibiotik in die Abwechslung nutzen.
Du bist zu Hause, du hast es nicht ausgebildet.
Du musst es nutzen, um zu sagen, dass du es nicht hast.